all right
uh welcome everybody thank you for
joining us this is
pi data hamburg welcome to our november
meetup
the last one for this year but you can
be sure there will be another year and
uh new pi data meetups we are aiming for
one every two months
and already in the process of organizing
um
before we start um you should know that
we are
from now on recording the session and
we're going to put
put it on the pi data youtube channel um
we encourage you to actively participate
you can unmute yourself
you can show yourself on the camera just
know that we can't cut this out so
if you don't want to show your picture
or your voice on the internet
you can always use the chat to ask
questions and communicate with us
um i think it's not a problem if you
just unmute yourself
and start talking but you can also raise
your hand here in zoom
so we know that you want to ask a
question later
and we're going to collect the questions
so is is there anyone here who's
completely new to pi data i wonder
now usually people are familiar but if
you're joining us for the first time
this may be your first
pi data event pi data is a global
community
for developers and users of open source
data tools
and it's an educational program of the
num focus
organization from the united states all
the pi data chapters they're
decentralized they're self-organized and
this is the meetup of the hamburg
chapter we
communicate with you through our twitter
pi data hamburg we have a linkedin page
you can find our recordings
on youtube on the depi data tv channel
my name is christian i'm a freelance
data scientist
and it's my pleasure to host this
tonight together with maria maria moya
de castro
a data scientist from the german climate
computing center
maria say hi to everyone
[Music]
yeah hi hi thank you for joining
uh also shout out to the rest of the
organizing team that's camilla
and yuming who helped us preparing their
meetups
and they're very very active in speaker
outreach
yeah i want to start off before we get
to the talks with
call for participation pi data is
completely volunteer driven
certainly our chapter is
like usually in open source so we're not
a close group we want to
encourage you if you feel like getting
active in the community
to join us and there are various ways
you can contribute
we're always looking for speakers if
you're building something interesting
with open source data tools
talk to us about it especially
if you're from underrepresented groups
and if you're a first time pi data
speaker we're going to help you prepare
your talk as well
then the organizing team could use some
help certainly if you want to
be active in speaker outrage and
coordination
and preparing the meetups you're very
welcome to talk to us and join us
yeah sponsorship is also possible for
companies
right now hosting meetup is really
lightweight
we need a zoom account but there will be
a time
after kovit where um we're going to move
to physical locations again and you can
certainly sponsor
as a company location and win some open
source karma
yeah our agenda for tonight we have
two matching talks it's all about the
cloud this time
first samantha is going to tell us about
uh have a comparison of the google cloud
platform and
the aws platform and in the second talk
alessandra alessandro is going to teach
us about
aws cdk the amazon web services cloud
development kit
in between the talks we are going to
have a short break of 10 minutes
and now i can head over to maria to
introduce the first
speaker and the first talk
it's totally a pleasure to introduce
samantha zeitlin i
met her in a really nice network it is
called
woman in machine learning and data
science and
also she has a couple of really cool
youtube
videos that please check it out later no
no no no no
later one is about a clustering
data science interviews and it's amazing
samantha because it's
still i mean whatever you said there it
still applies now nobody is it still
applies it
it will never be legacy unfortunately
and another videos he has really also
about what is
being a senior data scientist so
yeah yeah please please um samantha
okay i'm gonna share my screen
i think this is the right one oh hang on
let's share this one
i see that this is
okay you can see that okay
um well thank you for the invitation i'm
excited to
share things i learned the hard way
about the cloud
um and i really wanted to just kind of
summarize this talk
as methods for getting your python
into the cloud so the difference between
running python locally
and running it in a distributed system
remotely
and i'll try and give a very high level
overview there's a lot of content in
here
if people want to ask questions please
feel free to interrupt me or put things
in the chat but
um there's kind of a lot so if we get
through all of it great if not that's
fine
um who is this talk for i really wrote
this
for you if you are a data person
who uses python and
you've never worked in the cloud before
or
you've worked on one cloud platform but
you want to learn more about
another one or you're interested
in how to choose and use cloud services
because there are so many
and it can be really hard and
overwhelming at first to understand how
they all connect to each other
so the agenda i'll tell you a little bit
more about me
i'll tell you more about what i've done
with data in the cloud again very
high level stuff i'll briefly go over
why infrastructure as code is your
friend
and then i'll talk a bit about service
equivalence on amazon versus google so
that
you can kind of get an overview of which
things are the same
um i'll also touch on cost differences
that you might want to consider if
you're shopping around for
say a columnar database
services you won't find on both
platforms because they each have some
that are unique
to one or the other
and then i'll talk a bit about my biased
view of what's great about amazon and
what's terrible about it
and the same thing for google um totally
my personal perspective
and then if we have time and there's
interest i have some code snippets
to again sort of illustrate what i think
is easy and what's hard
about the different approaches for
interacting with the cloud with python
so really briefly um i was
not a cloud person for the first 20 or
so years of my career i was a cancer
research scientist
and i started with small data and by the
time i was
finishing up my postdoc i was doing what
would now be considered big data
but we weren't calling it that at the
time
and then like snakes on a plane the
inspiration for this talk
i had a very hard time getting people to
take me seriously as someone who knew
how to analyze data
so what i had to do was um
figure out how to get the right things
on my resume and that was mostly python
and sql
luckily for me i really like python it's
been about 10 years since i switched
over to writing code
um and i've been using amazon i started
at yahoo
i did that for a couple years and then
gcp for almost two years now also
so i'm not an expert by any means but
i'll give you my perspective as someone
who had to learn a lot of these things
on my own
and from docs so the kinds of things
that i'm
able to answer questions on again not in
depth on all these things
um databases that i've used the big
columnar databases i used redshift a lot
and bigquery this past year
i've done a little bit with athena and
some with firebase
um permissions i'll talk a bit about
today
because it's very important i've also
done a lot with
containers and kubernetes on both
platforms
mostly in pachyderm which is a service
that i've used for hosting machine
learning models and pipelines
um i've also done a fair amount of etl
both with streaming
and batch um this past year i did things
with pub sub and i supervised a team
that was using dataflow
when i was on aws i used pi spark on emr
and i've used airflow on both aws and on
gcp
and a little bit of cloud functions so a
little bit of serverless
i've also used looker on both aws and
they were recently acquired by google so
i've used that on both platforms also
okay i was going to make a
architecture overview but lucky for me
about a month ago this really nice
review came out where
they made this wonderful diagram that i
think does a nice job of summarizing
how a typical architecture overflow
looks
so on the left here whoops
you'll see there's a list of data
sources so you might be pulling in data
typically from databases that you
already have
um various event collectors within your
web app for example or your mobile app
logs third-party apis or a file or
object storage service
and i'll talk more about those and then
typically you have
some kind of streaming or etl step
so you're going to have some kind of
connectors that either transform the
data with sql or
python you might have this all in a
scheduler like airflow or
dagster then you might do additional
transformations with spark
or other kinds of python libraries like
pandas
and all of this will eventually feed
into
usually a data warehouse and often also
a data lake most of the time
by the time you've done all this
expensive processing with something like
spark
you want to back it up in s3 and in
addition you would load it into
a big database like snowflake bigquery
or redshift
if you're doing some kind of analysis
you're probably going to do both batch
or real real-time sort of streaming
analysis
and you might have a
historical look-back analysis as well as
predictive looking forward analysis so
these kinds of things you might want to
have in different containers or
serving on some kind of service that
lets you
connect them together and you might use
the same data sources
to do different kinds of models and then
you typically have another step
which would reformat the results of your
models
or your analysis to make it easier to
share with other people
so that might be dashboards and
something like looker or tableau
or superset or you might
put it in some sort of web app or
something
so that's kind of a lot of stuff and
this is part of why infrastructure as
code is your friend
historically everything on
the cloud was configured by one person
usually some expert person that you
would call the sysadmin
um and they did everything by hand and
that meant no one else at the company
understood how this stuff worked
and then a few years back we started to
shift over to having things in
configuration files
but usually that file still lived on one
person's hard drive and they were the
keepers of all the information and that
meant
if they were gone and something broke
you had to wake them up in the middle of
the night
so infrastructure as code now means that
um
everything is much more repeatable and
automatable
and it can live in version control which
means that it's kind of democratized and
software developers have a little more
control and we can actually roll it back
if we make a mistake
and i experienced this firsthand at
yahoo where we had configuration files
that lived on one person's hard drive
and they didn't do the best job of
keeping track and then something broke
and then we weren't sure which version
to roll it back to
all of those kinds of problems are gone
now and
one of the other reasons this type of
thing is useful is that if you have a
really big
cluster you can easily deploy the same
configuration to a bunch of different
machines
um the one caveat i'll say here is that
it can be
a security concern and you have to be
careful about what goes in your version
control
when you're talking about infrastructure
and i'll talk a bit about the security
aspect of this
just so we're all on the same page i
wanted to clarify some of the
terminology i'm going to be using
because
if you haven't been swimming in this
jargon a lot it can be kind of
overwhelming
so the way i talk about this stuff when
i say machine
i usually mean a hardware instance so
something like your laptop where it's
self-contained
hardware when i say instance that may
mean a whole machine or a part of a
machine
and that's because that's how they
typically refer to these things in the
cloud
so when you reserve an instance it may
be an independent machine or it may be
part of a machine that you're sharing
with other people
a virtual machine then is
a type of instance that has its own
system kernel that it's
self-contained and it can be running a
different operating system than the host
machine
and you can have several virtual
machines per hardware instance
similarly but distinctly containers
run this a different operating system
than the host machine
but they share the host kernel so that's
the main difference between a virtual
machine and a container
and you can have several different
containers per machine or
you might have a whole cluster of many
containers on many machines
and that's typically what we're talking
about when we're talking about docker or
kubernetes
and then serverless is a totally
different thing where you're reserving
pieces of a machine but you don't have
to worry at all about whether it's in a
container or a virtual machine
that's all taken care of for you by the
cloud platform
so there's service equivalence on aws
and gcp
for the basic functionality i'm just
giving you some highlights of things
that i think
i've used the most um so you'll find
storage
people often talk about s3 on aws that's
where your files live most of the time
um there's an equivalent on google
called google cloud storage gcs
um similarly there's a hosted version of
kubernetes on both platforms
those are both called kubernetes service
which makes it kind of convenient
there's also a container registry which
is something you need if you're
building a lot of docker containers and
you want to keep track of which version
container has
the current version of your code
identity access management
is one of the few that has the exact
same name on both platforms
and then there's equivalents for
serverless code execution
which have totally different names as
well as
virtual machine services so typically
people would refer to that as compute
and then there's services you won't find
on both platforms so amazon has
a hosted kafka that they call kinesis
they're pretty famous for their elastic
mapreduce which i've used for spark
redshift is very popular as a very large
database that was based off an old
version of postgres
and they also have athena which is a
time series database which is pretty
popular
kind of similar to snowflake
google now has looker they also have
hosted apache airflow
hosted apache beam which is a streaming
tool
as well as several databases that are
google only services
okay so this slide kind of summarizes
the main take-home points so
if you're getting overwhelmed i'll try
to give it give you all the high
points here um so step one to working in
the cloud you have to make sure that all
your credentials are correct
this sounds really obvious and trivial
and it's not so
i'll talk a bit more about why this is
important and confusing
there's also differences depending on
whether you're writing your own code or
whether you're using an sdk
but typically you need some sort of
interface to interact with
cloud platform services
you have to know quite a bit about the
different instance types
especially if you're making decisions
about how big should my service be
how fast should my service be
so you might need to know whether you
think you're going to want to optimize
for
input output versus storage or compute
there's also differences depending on
size and cost
so in some cases it makes more sense to
have a bigger cluster with a lot of
small instances
versus one bigger one and it might not
be obvious how that's all going to add
up in terms of the cost
there's also differences depending on
where you need to run in the world
and there's also differences on aws
i think google has an equivalent also
where you can reserve
on demand so machine space that's
available
unpredictably is cheaper it's shared
with other people
versus if you're willing to pay a little
more you can have reserved instances
that are always available for you
and then there's questions about scale
so
one thing that's very different in the
cloud that you usually don't have to
worry about as much locally
is just the fact that there's so much
data accumulating most of the time
if you're in the cloud usually you have
a lot of data so you need to set
time to live or basically expiration
time
for things that are accumulating or
and sometimes in addition you have to
have scripts that will help remove
things that are accumulating
so the kinds of things that are going to
accumulate would be say rows in your
database
at yahoo we were loading 40 billion rows
of data a day
which meant we had scripts that ran
every day to remove data that was more
than three days old because we simply
could not store it all
and the same thing happens for files in
s3 especially if you're backing things
up
and then you also need to consider do we
want to put say data that's a month or
90 days old
into long-term storage because you might
have
legal concerns for keeping a historical
record
but you simply cannot afford to keep it
all in s3 and there's usually no reason
to because you're
often not going to touch that data again
once you've already analyzed it
but there's a cost to pulling things out
of deep freeze
so there's some concerns there also we
can talk more about that later if people
are interested
um there's also other little gotchas
like i did not know that on google
you cannot set a time to live on your
containers so
if you have a bunch of containers in the
google cloud registry
you have to have a script that will go
through and remove the old ones when
you're done with them
so if you're updating your code all the
time and every time you deploy a new
version
you create a new container you now have
a giant repository with
hundreds of copies of this code most of
which is pretty similar to the previous
version
so at some point you have to start to
expire the old ones that you're not
using anymore
another little gotcha some regions are
more expensive than others
so for historical reasons amazon east is
a lot cheaper than amazon west
so things like that are worth paying
attention to because they do add up
at scale networking
concerns are also another thing you
might not have thought about if you're
just running on your local machine
so you would think that connecting
services within the same cloud
within an account that you own should be
easy
but it's not always that simple
and the distance might be a concern if
you're worried about latency because now
you're working in global
right and because you're working in a
global scale
there's also concerns about privacy and
those might be different depending on
the regions that you're operating in and
where your customers are from
so gdpr coppa
things like that you really want to be
very careful to consider
where are we retaining data how long are
we retaining data is it encrypted
does it need to be encrypted all these
kinds of things will slow things down if
you have to decrypt
when you transfer data all this kind of
stuff
um and one other little fun thing for
data science people
if you're used to running notebooks
locally you'll find that running them in
the cloud can be really slow
and might be more confusing
so cost differences as i mentioned at
scale
it becomes much more of a factor to
consider
so redshift is in some ways more
complicated at first because you have to
decide
what kind of instance types you want how
many so let's say i'm pretty sure i need
enough to control whatever several
millions of rows
i've got um some amount of
stuff that i know i need to process
fairly quickly i might want to optimize
for
input output over storage or compute
because i know that i'm spending most of
my time copying data
into the database and then retrieving it
out with queries
bigquery on the other hand you have no
control over any of that
you're sharing a global cluster
effectively
and you're going to get charged for
every query you run and that includes
both inserts and
retrievals but you also get charged for
storage so if the data is just sitting
there and you're not using it you're
still getting charged it's just at a
lower rate
and the other kind of awful gotcha about
bigquery is that you can't really
optimize
things by scaling up your cluster or
changing the type of instance you're on
you're pretty much stuck with changing
your schema and otherwise it's just
going to be as fast as it is and as
expensive as it is
you don't really have any control over
that
so bottom line there if you're running a
lot of queries
all the time like around the clock then
redshift can end up being cheaper
and if you're only going to run queries
a few days a week
it might be cheaper to view something
like bigquery so
these are the kinds of things that you
have to really sort of dig into the
details of how these services work
and how the pricing works so that you
can make an informed decision depending
on your
company's needs and your project's needs
all right so i mentioned that
credentials and and who you are is
really important
and again i'm going to define a couple
of terms hopefully this will help
clarify things
but when i say credentials usually i'm
referring to the set of keys that you're
using to log in
and when i say profile usually that is a
set of keys
or a role that you are assuming that has
a set of keys
and this will become clearer hopefully
as i go along
authorization is whether your role is
allowed and
authentication is the moment when you
actually
have your keys accepted when you've
actually logged in and if you've used a
lot of third-party apis you're probably
pretty familiar with authorization
versus authentication
but i just want to make sure we're on
the same page about that
so to make things simple i am roles
are a good thing you should use them um
if you're a new company and you haven't
done this before you might start out by
trying to configure permissions for each
person on your team or each service
separately
that will very quickly become a total
headache you're much better off
creating a role and configuring batches
of permissions and i'll explain a little
more what i mean by that
so a role might be something like
redshift reader where you would say
anyone who is an analyst or a person on
another team
they have access to read redshift but
they can't do anything else with it
another role then might be a data
engineer who would have
redshift reader as well as redshift
writer
as well as emr access and you can
combine
combine these together so they can
become hierarchical basically and you
can inherit
sets of permissions um
up to you know however many levels you
want and this makes it much much simpler
to add and remove batches of permissions
and to be much clearer on who has access
to what
another thing i want to emphasize google
pretty much forces you to use service
accounts now
um aws hasn't always made that as clear
but this also gives you a much safer way
to control
access to different services rather than
doing it on a per person basis
and then there's another whole layer on
top of
roles which you don't need to worry as
much about for gcp but for aws
is very important which is policies um
so just to give you a little hint here
there's six whole types of policies i'm
only going to mention four
aws makes you control and keep track of
identity-based policies so for users
groups or roles
resource-based so you can have
additional sets of policies that control
things like s3 buckets
which it's kind of cool that it's so
fine-grained that you can go all the way
down to an individual bucket
but that also means that it's another
thing you have to keep track of
you don't need to worry about access
control lists unless you're doing
cross-account access
which i don't recommend i have a whole
blog post about
why cross account access on aws is hard
but we can talk more about that if
anyone's interested
and then there's things like session
policies which you would hope you don't
need to know about
but some services actually require you
to renew a token every hour
and emr is one of these so your code
actually has to have an extra loop in it
to double check is my
session token still valid
okay so i know that all sounds really
boring and tedious
and you might be wondering why do i have
to care about this but
like i mentioned the gdpr child
protection act data security and privacy
rules
are a really big deal and if you're in
data you really do need to be aware
of who has access to the data what your
retention policies are
and ideally someone else on another team
would be keeping track of all this but
in my experience
the data team always has to know a lot
about it um
i've always had to do most of this
myself even at yahoo we had to do most
of this
ourselves so i pulled this quote from a
slack channel just this week i was
watching someone complain about having
problems with aws
and i thought this was great where she
basically says
we got stuck in a loop where we couldn't
do an aws action because we didn't have
the right permissions
so we assumed an admin role but the
admin roles policy
blocked it from doing anything so
this just gives you an example of how
confusing this can be
um so long story short this is a little
summary slide
you really need to have matching sets of
roles and policies
so for example in the little green
circle on the left here i am a data
scientist
i have a data scientist role which means
i'm allowed to use the s3 buckets in
this account
the bucket on the right then in the gray
circle
has a policy on it that says i'm allowed
to be used by people with the data
scientist role
and as long as all that stuff matches
you're good but um
the documentation has improved a lot is
the good news so
it's there's more examples and it's less
confusing
but this is something that really can
make or break
the amount of time you spend and the
amount of time you're able to spend on
your code
because it's very easy to end up with
um just errors that don't make sense you
don't know why your stuff is failing it
turns out it's a permissions error
but it won't necessarily tell you that
it'll just say fail
and you won't know why all right
having said all that cloud versus cloud
now hopefully we have enough background
to for you to understand
why i have the opinions that i have
um so what's great about aws
there's a lot of services they really
they have a lot of coverage
for everything you could possibly want
to do there's storage there's compute
there's databases there's streaming
um and it's very very secure they
generally
will not let you do anything stupid as
long as you follow their recommendations
and it's pretty easy to switch back and
forth between accounts you basically
have a profile
that keeps track of all your credentials
and then you can just switch to a
different
set of credentials redshift
i thought like i said it's pretty nice
um there were things about it that i
didn't love when i was using it but now
having used bigquery
there's things i miss about redshift
they also make it fairly easy for you to
log into your machine and
there's the observability aspect of it
is pretty good
i really didn't have any trouble getting
my logs or getting help when i needed
to debug things um they also make it
pretty easy
to access your profile from regardless
of what path you're in
on your machine which again you'd think
that wouldn't matter that much but
it's actually a major time saver
things i hate about aws
um the the key might be a symbol but the
ui is awful
um these cloud services the uis are just
absolutely terrible
it's hard to find things things aren't
labeled well it's hard to figure out
what's going on sometimes
um it's so secure that it's actually
hard to get work done
and this unfortunately can lead some
people to try to
cheat and that can actually make things
a lot less secure than they would be
otherwise
one of the examples of where why it's so
hard to use and it can actually make it
hard to get work done
is that if you want to log in from
another service
sometimes that's actually harder than
logging in from your laptop
and that's totally unintuitive if you're
not a networking and security person
there's also a lack of consistency
across a lot of those services so some
services require you to have a certain
type of role
and an additional policy others require
both some require
you know only one or the other so it's
very confusing
um and then there's these weird edge
cases like the one i mentioned with emr
and tokens where unless you really dig
into how the architecture works
it might not be obvious why it works
that way and you wouldn't necessarily
know
that this is something you need to worry
about
as i mentioned it's also very hard to
share things across accounts
okay so what's great about gcp
it's much much easier to use generally
um
there's more integrations across
services and they're simpler
and some of those examples would be it's
very easy to run
say a bigquery magic that lets you
connect directly to your database from
inside a notebook
the connections between pub sub dataflow
and bigquery are
kind of turnkey you just sort of click
boxes and it's done
um so overall i'd say it's much more
developer centric
it doesn't feel as much like it was
written by security professionals it
feels more like it was written by
developers so overall security is much
much simpler to configure
and you don't have to spend as much time
worrying about that
it's also easy to create multiple
projects per account
aws doesn't have an equivalent of a
project
so that makes it more complicated to
think about
how your architecture should work and
how you can break up services
and aspects of your application
okay gcp is not perfect unfortunately um
the ui is also bad it's probably just as
bad as amazon's just in a different kind
of bad
there are more problems with the code
changing so you're relying on
sdks that are often community
contributed
and they might be out of date
there's also a lot less support for
python than i would like
um they still tend to develop more for
java and javascript sooner
and python is sometimes lagging behind
for some of these services
observability is harder they have a
service called stackdriver that you
typically would hook up for your logs
and sometimes there are certain types of
log levels that you just can't even get
it's very unintuitive um and it's just
complicated to configure and weird
there's another thing you have to keep
in mind which is that they don't retain
their logs long term so
if your logs are hard to find or they
don't have everything you need
you can't hope that the google support
people will help you
because they're very slow to respond and
by the time they get back to you
they might have already thrown away the
logs from whatever the problem was that
you were having and that actually
happened to me
with pub sub
some other services like firebase are
still
really under construction so things that
worked last year
might not work this year because of the
way
they do their keys and the fact that
there aren't really profiles
a lot of times you end up with keys sort
of littered all over your machine and
you have a key and
copied all over different folders and
it ends up being kind of insecure in
that sense
all right so speaking python to the
cloud i don't know how we're doing on
time
um most important thing i have to tell
you
if you get nothing else out of this talk
you have to use logging
it isn't as important when you're
running locally you can just do print
statements whatever
if you're running in the cloud you are
relying on your logs as your primary way
to tell
what's working and what's not in your
application
um so the types of things you would log
are typically the same things you put in
a print statement
but usually you also want things like
timestamps file names that went in and
out of each step
and obviously errors you might also use
other kinds of third-party applications
like sentry or datadog to give you
additional observability
into your errors and your application
performance
python sdks are um
kind of limited still and i'm really
curious to hear alessandra's talk
because i'm hoping that that's going to
solve some of this problem
but historically the software
development kits that were available
weren't really software development kits
they're kind of just libraries
that give you some interfaces so the
main one people use for aws is photo3
it already knows how to get your
credentials out of your profile
and it has some built-in functionality
so there's already methods for
interacting with s3
and emr and people have written
additional wrappers that use
photo3 that make it a little easier
so the advantages to using a tool like
this is that you don't have to write
everything yourself from scratch but
the drawbacks are that you have to make
sure you're on the latest versions
and there might be major changes so like
the transition from both 2 to 103 was
super painful when we did it at yahoo
um and the documentation historically
has not been great
so it can be very hard to find examples
of the correct way to do certain things
it's not always obvious whether the
functionality really does what you want
or not gcp has kind of the opposite
problem
there's a ton of libraries out there but
a lot of them are defunct
so these are just a couple examples so
the one on the left was last updated six
years ago the one on the right was last
updated eight years ago
they both have the same name they have
totally different interfaces
and neither one of them works so
this most recent firebase app that i
built what i ended up having to do
was use the firebase admin library
and that knew how to get my token from
my local environment
everything else i had to do with
requests so i actually had to
build up the url myself and tell it
exactly where to look for my
database and my project and my
collection which is where all my
data lives within the database um
and that's the kind of stuff that i
would have thought there'd be more
automation around and it's
for python at least it's still harder
than it ought to be this stuff is much
nicer in javascript
for something like firebase which is
primarily used for
mobile apps these days
um i've got a bit more example code i
think we have time
um if people are interested or i can
stop there and we can take questions
should i keep going or we want to do
questions
i can't tell what the thumbs up means
okay thumbs up for yes questions
i don't know there was a question by
felix
there is only one so far for sure later
there will be more
if you ask me i would prefer that you go
on
okay i'll go quickly and then we'll
still have a few minutes
um so both aws and gcp have
uh command line interfaces that you can
install that let you set your
credentials
the aws one is pretty straightforward
there's only a handful of things they
ask for
the google side is a little more
confusing and
it may depending on what service you're
using ask you to enter more things
plus then you have to make sure that the
one you're using is active
so when i say check your credentials you
need to be able to do this both on your
local machine and sometimes if you're
logged into a remote
machine to make sure that the
credentials that that machine
or container are using is are the
correct ones
um so on the left you can see there's
um two profiles
in this example set of credentials so
one is the default and then one is
something they named user one um and
they have different sets of keys
it's really easy to switch between these
with the aws cli
and it's not that hard to check which
profile am i on on google
it's a little more confusing this is
just a stack overflow example but
basically you have to list how many
accounts do i have
you have to set the account that you
want to have active then you have to
list the projects within that account
and you have to set which project am i
on and there might be additional things
you have to set depending on what
service you're using
um and then i have an example with emr
just to give you
the full headache of what it is with aws
um so this is an overview map before i
show you the code because there's so
much going on i don't want it to be
super confusing so start out we know
we have our credentials that let us have
access to emr
and we're going to set up a cluster
configuration which
tells aws these are the types of
machines that i want
our python code is living locally on our
machine to start with but we have to
push it up to s3
so that the emr service can have access
to it
same thing where we need to push up
bootstrap code
bootstrap code is what you use to
install your python dependencies
into the cluster so
this all needs to happen in addition to
then pushing up your
spark job specs so that emr knows
what instance types how much of the
cluster to use for
your particular spark job
so here's an example um this is several
pages worth of code i'll try to go
through it quickly
you have to import voter 3 you're going
to use that
i've also used config parser in the past
because it makes it slightly simpler to
pull out particular parts of your
credentials
and if you're doing logging on the cloud
you're going to want to use a stream
handler
otherwise you're going to find that you
don't get all your logs back from the
cluster
so that's another thing that's a little
different from doing logging locally
then we've got a giant class this is how
i've done it in the past it's
not beautiful but it does give you a way
to keep
tabs on all the different configurations
so i've got this huge list of parameters
i've got a path to my local credentials
i've got a profile
a name for my spark job that's the
python file i'm going to use and i've
got a bootstrap
script so i'm going to pass all this
stuff in
i'm going to go through and parse out of
my configuration
all the information for the cluster so
region
number of instances i have to tell it
where to look for my logs to go
it's going to be an s3 path um
among other things so just moving
quickly here
um then you've got a whole step where
you have to set up the cluster
so you pass all this stuff in and you
say okay i know i want these types of
instances
the master instance that runs and it's
unfortunately this is
i don't know if this is still current
but the nomenclature they're using is
still considered unpolitically correct
um
you'd have a leader instance that keeps
track of the scheduling of the jobs
and then the worker instances that
actually run the job
then you'll have the number of instances
you want you need to decide things like
do i want my cluster to shut down if my
job finishes
or crashes because otherwise you're
gonna get charged
for that whole time while your cluster
is stuck or your job has failed
um on the other hand you can't debug if
you let your cluster shut down when
something crashes
so often when you're developing you want
to keep it in a mode
where it actually stays running even if
your job fails
and then you have to keep an eye on it
and log in as soon as anything fails and
try and figure out what's wrong
and when you actually submit the spark
job you have to tell spark
how much of the resources that are
available you want it to use
and how to allocate that those resources
um so that's more stuff that's sort of
spark specific
then you have to tell it okay bootstrap
here's the path to my bootstrap script
from s3 in order to install
all your python dependencies because
they otherwise they won't be there in
the cluster
finally before you can actually run the
job you have to tell emr
which version of python you want to run
because aws supports multiple versions
of python
and you may find that if you switch
python versions that your code won't run
the way you expected
um there's also additional stuff that
i'm not going to go over right now that
has to do with
encryption so you have to include
encryption keys
um and you have to specify which roles
have access to the encryption keys
so that's kind of a lot this is why you
want something like cdk
because otherwise it just ends up being
super complicated
um bottom line clouds are fun
it can be really expensive i strongly
recommend learning them
on somebody else's dime i learned most
of my cloud stuff at yahoo and trailer
um don't forget to shut down your
cluster
i fortunately never really had this
problem but i've heard horror stories
about people who
ran a job that failed or spun up
something to do a model and then forgot
about it
and ended up with hundreds of thousands
of dollars of bills
from the equipment that they had
reserved
don't be surprised if the docs are wrong
or out of date um
this is really common and uh you know
not that different from other kinds of
python but
it's even more confusing when you're
working with cloud stuff where you don't
have access to the code most of the time
and finally logging lot do logging
plugins your friend
uh acknowledgements i want to thank the
people who helped me out at yahoo
the hang up slap has been incredibly
helpful if you have questions about
security or cloud things
they're great people to ask um
so i mostly did aws at yahoo at century
i've done mostly gcp
so thank you to those people the
pachyderm guys have been tremendously
helpful in helping me learn more about
kubernetes
my partner also helped me with this talk
a little bit and thank you all for
inviting me
that's it
i'm trying to clap for uh 36 people
we can have a round of virtual plows
with the reaction button here
oh yeah right reaction button is
on um when you go to participants
that would be down there will be some
little icons i really like your talk
samantha i couldn't
follow everything i have to rewatch it
and i watch it the explanation was
awesome it's just me
oh so we have two questions um
christian if it's okay for you i think
we can make them now
because after alessandro talk alex
alessandro's talk there will be
plenty of time for all the questions but
now we only have two yeah okay
so let's go for for the question by
felix felix can
you mute yourself and ask the question
maybe it's better because my english
accent is horrible
well i don't know how bad my german
accent was actually
um i i
still seem to have it after four years
in australia still people
think it sounds strange um
so yeah i we are in a situation that we
are building
up a social media observatory so
we need some data warehouse solution
we're kind of
um determined on amazon web services
simply because they have a um
because there's by the dfns or the
german
research network it's kind of her it's
the australian students
um so it's just bureaucracy um so we are
kind of uh
locked on aws but
um i only have experience actually with
google cloud
and bigquery so i was wondering like how
hard would be to switch to redshift
i know you've done it the other way
around but
what do you think are the main obstacles
um that i should prepare for
i think honestly the biggest difference
is going to be that you can't really
dump json into redshift the same way you
can with bigquery
so i think that's one of the things that
you either love or hate about bigquery
right is being able to actually query on
json um
redshift doesn't handle that very well
so
you might have to do more etl basically
to get your data into a more
um cleaned up structure because it
really is a
more of an old school relational
database that way but otherwise i think
it's mostly pretty easy
and if you decide that you want to
change
instance types for example they've made
that pretty easy too
it's all fairly automated now and you
mostly just click buttons and tell it
okay i want to go to back this up
and here's my new cluster and then let's
copy over to my new cluster
it'll tell you how long it'll take um so
that's all pretty friendly now
and a lot less scary than it used to be
that's good to hear because that was one
of my main concerns because it's
impossible to predict like
exactly what people need i mean it's
it's real world data i don't know yeah
well and it's pretty normal that you
might have to scale your cluster up
over time right you might start with one
or two instances and then find
actually now we need three or four so
yeah i i thought that this function
should exist but i
thought often enough that something
should exist and then
you had to do it by hand so you know
it's like
so that's good for you thank you
thank you felix i i think christian has
also
a question uh yes first of all thanks
samantha for the great overview
and since you talked about spark on aws
i was wondering if you've heard of a
tool called flintrock
that's there to help you to quickly spin
up the spark cluster in aws
and i've only used it for small
educational demonstrations but it made
the setup
fairly easy but that's not really in
production so i was wondering if you
know
anything about it and would it would
make your workflow
easier yeah i don't know
i think there's a lot of people who use
the spark submit
command line style where you basically
just end up with a long
command with a bunch of parameters
attached to it
and i personally don't like to do it
that way because i've found that it's
much more error prone
and that's part of why i do it in this
giant json format
um the one advantage to doing it in the
json format is that once you've set it
all up
usually you only have to make minor
modifications and it's easy to share and
it's all version controlled and
all of that good stuff so that's part of
why i've done it that way
um but i haven't really looked enough at
flint rock to see
how that all works in terms of um
configuring it and if it's easy to
version control
and avoid those little typos that we all
tend to make
thank you are there any more questions
okay we'll stop there for now
thanks again come up later after
alessandro's talk
i mean questions also for samantha i
mean
so okay before we go to alessandro's
talk
we are going to go to a quick break of
10 minutes so
let's meet again at
7 35 here for alessandro's talk thank
you
wow
i am back i am back i totally didn't
leave
like samantha right
we were here
yeah i don't want to start without
christian
i'm here ah awesome
and alessandro is here yeah
so we're ready welcome back from the
break everyone
um let me introduce you to
our second speaker in the cloud
alessandro romano
who works as a data scientist for a
logistics company
called carbonx here in hamburg and i'm
really looking forward to this i'm
hoping to learn
a lot more about infrastructure as code
alessando this stage is yours yeah many
times
okay let me show my slides
okay hope you can see them well
perfect yeah many thanks so
um just a few words about me my name's
as you know is alessandra i'm working
for a logistics company
as a data scientist uh eventually
i left like a few links here so you can
reach me out on linkedin
github or medium so this talk is about
aws cdk cdk stands for cloud development
kit
and we will go through how to provision
your cloud application using python
so i know that we have like people that
are somehow familiar with the cloud
uh maybe it's maybe i mean there are
some people that actually are not
so this presentation is for everyone
actually so you can
um you can understand what cloud
computing
means and why we're going through this
kind of topics
and if you're already familiar with the
cloud computing you will get to know a
aws cdk so how to deploy your
application with cdk
so we will start with a brief
introduction about cloud computing then
we move
to uh infrastructure as a code
and the implementation of infrastructure
as a code
uh aws cdk provides actually i mean
amazon provides actually an
implementation of this
uh infrastructure as a code and it's
called cdk
then we will we are going to see
a really nice and small
[Music]
use case uh so we're going to build this
small application with python and cdk
and in the end of this presentation
we're going to check out
why you should look for i mean why you
should actually check out
cdk why you maybe why you maybe want to
use it
and what kind of um
you know things you can actually take
from this talk
so the cloud computing as a service i'm
really happy because samantha actually
gave us a really nice introduction of
a lot of interesting things from aws and
google cloud
um so just to keep it really simple
um cloud computing is usually about
hiding
a lot of complexity so you want to focus
on the application you want to build an
application you want to develop
so you don't want to manage the system
manage the data center you don't want to
do this stuff you just want to
focus on the code you want to write for
your application
so cloud computing as a service is about
that so you can imagine for instance
a really nice time series services uh
service that is actually that allows you
to uh
work with time seriously so you just
have to
uh submit your data and then do some
analytics and forecasting
uh but you don't really maybe deploy
also some model if you
if you want but you don't really have to
take care of the complexity under who so
you won't
uh administrate anything of uh the
infrastructure that is actually built
under the hood but you just have to
somehow look at the front-end
implementation of this service
but actually we do have a lot of
complexity under the hood that we don't
want to take care of
this is a a bit outdated
actually overview of the amazon services
so the logos
are not the actual ones so in the in the
next slides you will see different logos
for the
services that we're going to use but
this gives you
a really nice overview of the services
from aws cloud
um in this presentation we're going to
focus on
aws lambda uh s3 bucket
and amazon api gateway uh i can say
these are probably three of the most
famous services
pretty users especially s3 is basically
used for
for everything so
let's jump to cloud computing in
practice
so a really nice example is aws lambda
a double islam that personally is
something that i use i would say
every day uh it's a serverless compute
service
and it allows you to basically focus on
the code
that you want to write for your
application so that means that you
just have to write just to give an
example the code for your
etl and you don't have to
take care of manage the infrastructure
under hood but you just have to
somehow deploy the code of your etl
and this can be done with aws lambda
but of course under the hood we do have
some complexity so we have
in this case lambda is based on is
implemented with docker
um we do have some linux machines we
have auto scaling and much
more but what you just see is a place
where you can upload your code
and then you can run your application as
a serverless application
and this is also really nice point
because serverless means
that you always that you can run your
application on demand so you don't have
to spin up
um proper instance for instance
like a proper ec2 instance but you can
just focus
on a service serverless application that
is actually run
every time you need it so as i said
aws lambda is something that we're going
to see
and now let's define what
a stack is in this case of course a
stack of services
so a stack is basically a collection of
all the services that you need within
your application
and here we have a really
nice example of a design of an api
api based of course on lambda
so we have the amazon api gateway that
we will that will take care of
um trigger the lambda function so we get
the um so once we trigger the lambda
function
we can basically take care of the
request and then
do whatever we want in this case this
lambda function is going to write back
something into the database
um you can see this example like as an
api or maybe you can also think of this
design
for an etl as i just said
so how do we deploy
our stack in aws we have cloud formation
cloud formation is a service that allows
you
to deploy your stack by using
a template so the template uses usually
is a json or a yaml file and it
basically describes you
all the resources and the dependencies
that you need
to deploy your stack and
why do you want to do that i mean you
can easily
basically you can easily open the aws
console
and click a few buttons and basically
spin up initiative instance create a
lambda function so do
exactly what we can see here so we can
create this this
this stack through aws to the aws
console from the browser
but this is not what we want to do of
course because if you do that you can
you cannot really reproduce it so you
you're not basically keeping track of
the changes
but instead what you want to do what you
want to do is using for instance
cloudformation create a template
that basically defines your stack
and then submit this template to aws and
create
all the resources that you needed that
you need for your application
and this means that you can have some
control
on what you're doing you can update your
stack
you can modify it uh and of course once
you put it on git
on github you can you you basically have
some fashioning
and you keep track of all the changes
now uh provisioning with cloud formation
so cloud formation is a really really
important service
and if you if you want to deploy
something
you have to know cloud formation you
have to know somehow how how
transformation works
so cloud formation of course
i mean it's a really important service
but in the same time
it has some downsides so first of all
confirmation uses template
and this template as i said are
basically yaml file or json files
and this is not actually a programming
language so
um it's almost free text you can have
some helps from your editor
but most of the time it's it's not
really
i mean it's not really handy work with
this kind of files
then the second point is that you don't
have any guarantee
that your stack is correct so most of
the time you have to deploy to
i mean usually you have to deploy to
understand if you're doing something
right
you have to wait and if you have like a
really big application you have to wait
a lot
and then in the end you will see that
something was wrong so
not really nice um the third point is
that
cloud confirmation to plates lack
obstruction
so that means that you have sometimes
you have to specify
too many stuff too many things in your
template
uh and it's not really handy because
let's say you just want to deploy a
really simple api with
that consists of api gateway
lambda function and maybe a connection
to the database as we
uh saw in the as we just saw in the in
the in the previous slide
um you really don't want to define
things
which are not necessary from like an
application point of view so you want to
have some
abstraction you want to say okay we just
want to define a lambda function
but i don't want to take care of so many
parameters
but we do have like an alternative
this alternative is called aws cdk
um with aws cdk
we can basically define our stack with
the programming language
so fws cdk is implementation of
infrastructure as a code as
as you can imagine is basically
it means that you're going to define
your infrastructure with code
and you can use a programming language
in this case cdk actually provides
um can be used with python typescript i
think
java maybe and some other languages in
our case of course we're going to focus
on python
so uh first of all as i said you can use
the programming language
and then in my case i use pycharm
i get a lot of help from pycharm so
pycharm can actually
or any kind of editor can actually helps
you to
understand if you are writing the right
things
into your slack if you into into your
stack so if you're actually defining
your stack in the
in a proper way in the right way um
the the third point that
actually i i would say
it's uh looks like trivia looks like
something you don't really want to take
care of but it's really important
it's built on top of cloud formation so
you do have the power of cloud formation
it's
not something completely new
you can think of you can think of city
gate like
an interface of cloud formation
basically
um then you can use some logic you can
use
if statements for loops uh this is
actually an example so here we have
in the lambda function definition we
have
f we have basically a string formatted
with python
that contains which contains lambda dash
id and the id is basically a variable
coming from
another part of this code uh and this is
really interesting so
because basically you can use your
programming language
and you can do whatever you want within
your stack
and it's easy to share
and reuse also this part looks trivial
but it's not
in this case this is a lambda function
but
every time that i have to define a
lambda function or i have to define
a the rest api as you can see here i
always go back to the projects that i've
built so far
and i picked all the pieces that i need
to the new stack
and i can tell you this is not
something like they
do for which you can say okay uh
i don't really care i do care because i
have a lot of projects for which i use
cdk
and i really need to go back and be able
to
reuse the code that i that have written
so far
so uh let's build our first application
so i decided to show you this study case
uh it's a really simple one uh but it's
actually
something that i have that i had to deal
in the past several times so it's
it's not like something that i made for
this talk it's a
real life problem i would say um
first of all the problem is about
deploying the rest api
for our machine learning model for the
people that are
into like machine learning concepts
we're talking about
inference so it's not it's not training
but we want to use the model
with the train so this is in a machine
learning pipeline is called the
inference
uh the context we
are training a model every night and
then we save
this model into an s3 buckets you
probably already know tanks this amount
samantha you probably already know
what's uh
what an s3 bucket is um so we basically
save the model
into this uh storage space
uh of course we assume this is already
implemented it's not part of this talk
the solution is retrieving the model
from a lambda function
which will be called by a gateway and
then we deploy everything with cdk
as you can see here we have the design
of what we want to implement so we have
uh an amazon api gateway it will take
care of that will take care of the
requests
and then of course to send back the
response
this amazon api gateway will trigger the
lambda function
the lambda function contains the code of
our application in this case it's about
retrieving the model from s3 use the
model to make the prediction
and build the response so we will get
back
a json that can be used uh i don't know
in another context and the json of
course will contain
um the prediction and
as i said we read this information from
s3
and the model somehow is already saved
in a stream
by someone else not us
okay the cdk project structure so
before looking into the proper code
let's see how we have to set up the
project
and how what kind of packages do we need
so uh first of all we have a lambda
the the code the lambda code basically
the code that we want to
uh upload in the lambda function so
in this case i created a lambda
directory uh
it's not necessary but i mean for
convenience you want to do that
and here we're going to store the code
of our application and in this case it's
called api backend.pi
then we have the first cdk file
the python implementation of our stack
so in this file we're going to
define how our stack
looks like and this means defining all
the resources and all the dependencies
that we need to deploy the stack
and in the end we have the cdk json um
we don't really have to focus on this
file as usually by default you don't
have
you only have like json with one field
but i can tell you this is really useful
and i usually use
it a lot i put a lot of parameters in it
maybe we'll do another talk about it
it's definitely worth it um
so step number one we have to install
cdk
um you can have i mean you you can just
look at the aws
documentation it's pretty
straightforward
i think you should use node.js once you
have cdk on your machine
and of course an aws account
because you have to set it up then you
can start to
with the first like instruction that is
about initiate your project
then the second step is installing
all the packages that you need for your
application that means
aws lambda aws s3 ews
gate api gateway uh this is what we
decided during the design basically
okay now we can have a look at the close
so let me switch to
pycharm here we are
i hope you can see it
so let's start with the
app.pi so this is basically
the project that i decided to implement
so this is based on the use case that we
just
saw and this is what i decided to
implement
so first of all we imported all the
libraries that we need for the project
that means the lambda
api gateway s3 of course this is lambda
dash because
lambda as we probably know is already
taken
from python and the first step is
creating the main class
this is also pretty trivial i mean it
more or less it's always the same
uh source we just have to
create this header for the class and
then
use the code.stack class and we're
basically done
now we use which we go to uh the
definition of the services that we need
within our stack
um first of all we say that we need we
need a lambda function
so let's start implementing it in the
lambda function
as you can see we are basically calling
lambda.function this means that we're
going to create an object
i think sorry an attribute that is uh
based on the lambda function type so
what we're going to do is first of all
defining an id
usually this has to be unique the way i
like to make it unique is
by formatting the string with in this
case
lambda dash id id is basically the name
of our stack the name of stack is coming
from here
and why do we know that this is why we
should this is unique
because we cannot upload a stack with
the same two stacks with the same name
then we have to specify what the code is
so code equal to lambda asset called
lambda so this
basically this is basically telling to
uh lambda where the code is located and
this
in this case we just say that the code
is located in the lambda
directory then we have to specify the
handler
so just to be clear these are all
arguments that are not
so basically this these are concepts
that are not related to cdk
but instead this is all about
defining creating a lambda function
so now we have to specify the angular
really easy the handler is basically the
main function of the lambda
function that we created in this case i
can
already give you a glimpse of what we're
talking about
so this is the lambda handler so the
lambda handler is located in the
api backend file and the function name
is lambda handler
then we can define like a few common
stuff for every python
application for every lambda application
that is the timeout the memory size and
the runtime
we don't really care for now about this
information but of course in real
context you want to
think of how much memory and what's the
timeout of your lambda function
then we switch to
the api gateway definition
so we can already see that we have
really
uh built-in um
metered for the lambda rest api um
this is basically also something
really nice because that means that if
you want to build
a rest api you already have something
that does the job for you
um with the rest api with the lambda
rest api we just have to
of course define um the id
of this uh api gateway resource
the handler so that means okay once you
call
uh this um
this api what do we have to do what do
you have to do
i have to call i have to trigger the
lambda function
and in this case the lambda function is
the one we just defined
so we say handler equal to lambda
function
and then the rest api name
we are almost done because the last
thing that we have to define
is the bucket so we say that we want to
read the model from the s3 bucket
that means that we have to give the
lambda function the permission to read
the bucket
how can we do that we just have to
create
a new bucket entity
and we do that with s3 packet from
bucket name
and we just pass as an argument as a
parameter
the test bucket that is basically the
name of the packet
where the model is located and now we
can definitely give
the lambda function the rights to read
any files from this packet
and in the end we just have a few uh
lines of code um that are basically
about
creating the object that is our stack
the pi data model and then deployed
once we're ready to call basically uh to
execute the cdk deploy command
so let's have a look at the cdk json as
i say this is
this is quite simple i mean you don't
have to do anything
it works out of the box you just have to
define
uh app equal to python 3
app.pi this basically saying today is
telling to
cdk that we're going to use python 3 for
this application
because as i said you can use different
kind of languages like
typescript i think java c-sharp i don't
really
remember but potentially
just to give you also uh an idea of how
you can use this file
you can actually pass through cdk some
parameters so
what you can do for instance is defining
some
max time and then
for instance 500 and then basically you
can use this max
time within this file and parameterize
the stack so you can parameterize the
definition of the lambda function so you
here in in this part of the code you can
use the max time
that you defined in the cdk json
now let's have a look at the
core of our application so here
is where we define uh
basically the core of the api
so he here is where we define what the
api does
every time that we call the api
as we said we don't really have a model
on s3 so get model from s3 is not doing
anything
potentially you can use boto3
and with five lines of code you can just
retrieve your model
uh of course we don't have like a proper
model on stream at the moment
also make prediction just to let you
understand
is not really doing anything because we
don't have a model this is just like a
fake binary classification so we will
return true or false based on some
probability
but nothing special so first of all
once we trigger the lambda function
so triggering the lambda function means
that we call the api
so once we trigger the lambda function
we want to read
the parameters the parameters so what
does this mean so
let's say this is the link of our api
if we basically do
a get if we make a get request we can
pass this three these two parameter
parameters to the
uh function that's we have
age and country and then we want to read
them
this can be easily done through the
event
um variable um
then we want to retrieve the module from
s3
as i say this is not doing anything but
potential this is what we're going
to do we have the rights to do that
and in the end we read
the results so we the result of the
prediction so we call make prediction
it takes this argument the model
uh in the two parameters agent country
uh we think we can think if you're
really interested we can think of this
as a model that says if you're going to
get married in the next six months i
don't really know
um and then basically we have
the response of this api
how do we build that so also this is
basically coming from the documentation
we don't really have this is not rocket
science this is nothing special
we just have to define the body
of the response in this case the body
the json that we send as a response
is about one argument that's
prediction and then we're going to
attach the result
so now we have all the components that
we need to deploy our application so we
have the definition of the stack
we have the cdk json that is mandatory
if you want to create a cdk application
and then we have our api so we have the
code
that we're going to deploy into the
lambda function and now we can jump
to
the next step that is
deploying so finally now that we have
all the components of our application
we can just run cdk deploy aws
accounts is uh probably set up and if
you're ready to do all the stuff that
you
that you usually used to do with aws cdk
you can easily deploy
your stack up your application so uh
from now on once you run deploy you will
basically get a really nice summary from
cdk
that will show you what kind of services
and what kind of dependencies you have
within your stack so basically you have
an overview of the things that you're
going to
deploy uh i can't really show you that
because i'm using my aws account so
i'm not really sure if i can actually
i'm afraid
maybe i will somehow spoil some i don't
know secret links from aws
so i decided to not to show you the
summary but
it's really straightforward so you don't
really um
you don't really have to do any
particular actions you just have to
run cdk deploy and um it's done
so likewise once you have um
your application deployed uh you can
just run cdk destroy and get rid of it
that's all so
a few considerations first of all
in my opinion infrastructure as a code
is already a standard so
i think that this is the definitely the
direction
we want to go so we're moving in that
direction so a lot of developers are
using it so it's definitely some
something you should check out
uh no matter like your background or
what kind of job you want to do
just check it out
then i think cdk is a really elegant way
to
deploy your application um
and if you have to decide unless you
don't have like specific constraints
just think of cdk as a first option
uh because it actually it can really
boost like
your job somehow your work
now this is also for me
since i'm a data scientist so this is
also about data science
so i think that as a data scientist you
can
really take care of a lot of data
engineering
concept by using cdk without
administrating anything and without
dabbing
diving into maybe some
cloud formation or terraform complex
templates
so i think you can i mean having the
chance to use python
to define your application it's a really
big thing and as a data scientist
you really want to add these to your
skill set
but of course we also have some
downsides
probably the first one is that i mean
you have to learn something new
every time that you as you as i shown
you i mean
you can have uh you actually have to
deal with some
cdk libraries so you have to read the
documentation
you have to go through some examples and
unfortunately since this is something
readily new it's not really hard to find
the right example for your problem
for the problem you're going to solve uh
so this is a big thing you want to take
in account
and most of the time i have to deal with
this
uh and then in in the end i will say
cloud formation bugs are also cdk bugs
uh we say that cdk is actually based on
cloud formation
so if you have something that is not
working on cloud formation
you will have the same problem in cdk
and personally i went through this kind
of issues in the past so
just be careful and
yeah i would like to thank you all
especially paideita for this really nice
opportunity
and thankful samantha really nice talk
and please just raise your hand in case
you have questions
thank you alexander let's have a round
of applause
there are a few questions from the chat
um first of all dennis was curious about
your editor which editor are you using
and how do you get the docs strings to
appear
so now i'm using pycharm basically
[Music]
as you can see from here so this is the
python logo uh i'm using python
and basically uh from if you use cdk
since you're using proper python objects
um you can basically yeah you get the
help of
pycharm or intellij
probably uh visual studio
2. yeah that's pretty straightforward
you don't really have to do anything
special
and samantha is curious what kind of
bugs do you run into
so um one bag that was real annoying
uh if i remember well was
accessing uh some
s3 um data and i don't really remember
the special
use case but it was about accessing
having the right success
s3 uh files so
okay there was a part basically okay i
had some problems when i had to
trigger the lambda defining the trigger
the lambda from
an s3 packet an existing s3 bucket so
basically i was receiving
raw data into this s3 bucket
and i wanted to build a trigger for
lambda function
but somehow uh this is a well-known
issue
um and yeah i mean i was actually
having a lot of problems defined trying
to define this
with cdk and in the end i found out that
that
was uh it is a
cloud formation uh issue um
yeah so my advice will be please if you
if you see that something is not working
with cdk and if you're really sure that
you're following
the sometimes bad documentation
please check the cloudformation issues
on github
some follow-up questions are coming on
the editor
dennis also wants to know they have
preferred sources to debug cdk
and object-oriented programming in
general
oh sorry can you repeat the question
we can read it from the chat do you have
some preferred sources to debug
cdk and object-oriented programming in
general
uh so
i mean i use pycharm and try to debug it
with pycharm but usually
i never had to like
i mean as a data scientist that i'm not
really involved in
uh like developing or maybe deploying
a really big applications so i didn't
run into this kind of problems
um yeah i mean the bagging with pycharm
is usually more than enough for me
um yeah if you have any ideas maybe i
will be happy to
yeah have a look at it
so abhishek asks is there any problem
with other ides
probably not just
would you say pycharm is a lot better
than jupiter or spider
to work with uh cdk
well the question so uh comparing
uh python with jupiter is probably not
fair um i mean i use pycharm i use
first of all i use jupiter a lot
uh for data analysis for uh
machine learning i mean of course
jupiter is part of what i do
um but of course when i have to
develop the application or when i have
to develop some kind of
uh etl uh that basically involves
building a stack and deploying the stack
with cdk
i think python is the way to go i don't
see how you can
really use jupiter in this case
and you told us cdk just check it out
it's already a standard it's coming
um i'm taking you seriously here but i'm
also wondering
i do occasionally some stuff with
aws like simple things setting up
a workstation with the gpu and jupyter
lab and things like that
um i'm wondering when when does cdk
really become useful would you recommend
that i also do simple things in cdk if
i'm comfortable with python
so um it really depends
i mean in general short terms for pro is
probably
yes i mean just less of a you can have a
look at this
kind of framework uh but of course the
long answer
is it depends on what you really have to
do
if you if you just want to spin up like
an instance
an initiative instance
maybe you don't you don't really have to
work with cdk you can just
spin it up and then use it uh
but maybe if it's about building
as we just saw like a small inference
module uh that is going to be deployed
in production and you want to have like
also
a test environment and a stage
environment
uh i think working through the aws
console from the browser
is probably not the right idea the right
thing to do because
then you cannot keep track of everything
anything basically
so you really want to uh have some
versioning under the hood
and maybe cdk it's uh if you have to
start from scratch i would say okay
why you really want to bother yourself
with cloud formation just
let's have a look at cdk okay thank you
is there anything you would like to know
from uh alessandra and maybe also from
samantha if you've
thought of another question to her um
not really uh maybe maybe the only
question would be
uh what if she has experience with
experience with cdk and if
what kind of understood bad experience
she had
with sdk
yeah i haven't used cdk um
my experiences with sdks like i said
they're
when they're up to date they can make
your life a lot easier
um i have a whole blog post on like
using s3 fs which is a wrapper on top of
boto3
um for like listing s3 buckets and stuff
like that
um personally i think the more
automation
for things that you do multiple times
the better i think it's worth it to
write the time to you know spend the
time to write the code to automate
things
um the trick is it's kind of similar to
doing other types of data science that
often you do something once and you
think well this is just a one-off
it's fine if i just do it in a notebook
or whatever and then
after you've done it two or three times
you say you know what maybe i should
write some helper functions
maybe i should automate this um so i
think that's
the same kind of mindset you need to
have about all of this stuff
um one thing i was going to say was your
comment about
the lambda functions not triggering on
files being written into s3
the setup that you were using um
pachyderm actually
uses does that use case perfectly so
that's one of the things i liked about
using them for deploying
models and and handling all that stuff
because they already have functionality
that knows how to watch s3 buckets
and they have automatic egress so if you
want to you can just
tell it i want to write out to s3 here's
the path and it handles all that for you
um so i think there's a lot of
competition right now for
what's the right way to handle how do we
want to serve our machine learning
models and
there's a ton of different tools coming
out and there's always the option to run
it yourself
in a cloud function or a lambda or
there's several other options for
deploying um
and i'm really curious to see what's
going to happen in that space because i
think right now
data scientists we're spending a lot of
our time on
mlaps and having to figure this stuff
out
and it's not the best use of our
expertise right we get to spend like 10
percent of our time building models
and that's the easy part and then we
spend the rest of our time
fighting with aws docs you know yeah
yeah that that's a really good point and
this is basically what i went through
uh several times and uh yeah now
there is a lot of confusion because we
do have a lot of
like different choices um i will say in
general
infrastructure as a code is definitely
the right way to go
but then you always have to choose the
framework
so you always like in the same position
like okay
god i know that i have to do some work
now
and have to choose the right framework
for my problem
um but yeah let's let's see what is
going to happen
but i totally be with you um and of
course spending
time understand like trying to
understand
how to use also uh cdk
uh i mean it's it's it's a big deal
it's a big deal it's not just like
looking at some documentation and all
especially when i don't find and this is
what is happening because now it's been
a long time that i'm using it
especially when i don't find the right
um example for my problem
uh and i know that i have to go through
the documentation
um and some sometimes it's really hard
because you're like oh okay
i have to try out stuff for two days at
least
and and of course i mean that's that's
like uh
you know your company's problem then
they're like
paying you for this kind of job uh
because then you have to
actually use your time in that way
and and you also have to to find the
right person that is
able to manage this kind of topics so
yeah i know what you're talking about
yeah and actually i forgot to mention we
did use terraform
at my last company um and it is
better than trying to manage i am roles
only through the ui
yeah because then you do have a history
of what someone's permissions were
previously and you can copy roles around
more easily
yeah exactly but that also has there's a
little bit of a learning curve that
there's different ways to set up the
inheritance
and the abstractions um and that's
changed a lot just the last couple of
years
terraform's been under rapid development
too
um we also used helm at one of the
places i worked for
kubernetes things that's also its own
it's like its own domain specific
language that you have to learn this
whole system
so um yeah i mean i think ideally
all companies would understand that they
need to have a whole ops team
just to support data efforts and
my experience has been that usually they
don't allocate enough head count
for that um yeah hopefully ops team is
busy supporting engineering and they
kind of data is sort of an afterthought
yeah
yeah yeah lately it's it's not really
common to see devops
open roles i don't know what is
happening exactly maybe
the scientists are working too much
probably
we don't have to call devops anymore
yeah
i i still remember like years ago when
people
were really obsessed and into this uh
zappa i don't know if you know it zappa
was like for deploying machine learning
stuff
uh the name is zappa and also also
sam was really common from from aws
i mean there was like a time there was
so many different frameworks
and and it was always like trying out
different things
and i was like okay i think it feels
like i'm switching
roll uh was really weird but yeah
let's see what's going to happen
i have a question christian but maybe
someone else
so sometimes there are no more questions
on the chat people comment they like to
talks
so maria go ahead okay okay um
i think now you're in meals
now you're weird i i speak alone
it's for samantha but for sure
alessandro knows a lot for sure the
thing is that i
listened i had a newcomer to the cloud
topic
and i listened to a talk by ibm it was a
promotion of the
services cloud services and i must say i
never hear in my life any scandal
about ibm all the big texts
you know but ibm you know
so um what they pointed like
strongly or at least what i got is that
they are the only ones ibn is the only
ones offering
a cloud that is hybrid like you still
have
data on your data center
and only part of the data are in the
cloud if you want
so you don't have to give and sell your
show to
evil like totally but then then in
wikipedia i look for it and with the
video set about amazon but i don't find
it now
that also amazon offers that that like
you don't have to
move the whole data to them so i want to
know
what is the truth i think a lot of
companies are working on hybrid cloud
offerings and historically
a lot of people had hybrid like at yahoo
we had hybrid because yahoo had their
own infrastructure
and we had things in aws um
i think it's more common in some sectors
than others so
like in healthcare and in finance
sometimes they're so worried about
security that
they have everything locally and then
they might have a little bit of data in
the cloud
but mostly they want to keep things out
of the cloud because they're worried
about
access and that so thank you so much
supply flight
this so then everything you said so far
it will change a lot or more or less the
same like
from a pure cloud and a hybrid cloud
things are completely different or more
or less
honestly i i think they're still mostly
pretty separate
and it's kind of hard to bridge across
um and generally i think
when people say hybrid cloud sometimes
they also mean across
different platform services um
so i you know it's a moving target i'm
not
really qualified to comment on where the
where that stuff is all going but um
i there are also there's this other
whole thing where people are building
very large machines
and sometimes those make more sense to
have
your own um or it might be owned by a
different company
so for some types of deep learning for
example or other types of real-time
analysis
um that might not be available through a
cloud platform so then you might
need to have a hybrid for that reason
but
um yeah i think there's there's just a
ton of stuff out there
and there's a lot of investment and um
i think depending on what company you
end up at
you know it's worth it to ask these
things in interviews you may
be surprised to find out that for
example they can't let you work remotely
because all of their equipment is on
site
um i think most companies probably are
having to work around that because of
the pandemic but
there were places that i spoke to even
just a year or two ago
where they said you know we're we're in
healthcare insurance or whatever and
everyone has to use a key card to get in
the building and we don't let you
take things home on your laptop at all
so
that would be a reason to have your own
machines
felix had another question fix do you
want to ask directly
yes a question to allah actually
one and a half two questions um
so i really find this uh serverless
lambda stuff very interesting because it
seems to make a lot of things
way less complicated but um i have
like one question is pretty easy how
like how is it well
no it's not that easy um i'm not sure
either
is there any way to compare it cost wise
to
a more traditional solution
um like just having your machine or
using sdk or whatever
and how does that comparison go
like in a comparable case i it's hard to
think up a case in my head right now
that
you where you actually would have a
solution that would be
equally practical in both
systems but the other question is um
it's from from what i see it's a pretty
amazony uh thing so
don't you um aren't you afraid that all
your applications
are kind of get kind of locked in into
the amazon
ecosystem compared to a not serverless
solution which you can easily move
from server to server for example if you
have like
containers or whatever okay
so answering the first question so
um i can give you like i i didn't really
compare
um this is probably already done by the
marketing when they sell you
the service i really didn't compare like
lambda
aws lambda with um like another service
from from aws like on paper really
didn't do this
this thing but i can tell you that
like a common scenario where you want to
use lambda instead of
an initiative instance is when you have
to
so one example is the one that is
showing you but in general when you have
to
write like a simple etl for a simple etl
you have um you don't have a lot of
constraints with pi
with lambda and usually you have a max
time like the time
you can you can run the the code in
python and
the max amount of memory that are really
high
so you can really deal with huge
etl honestly uh and this is a really
cool like case
for like that you can use for comparison
because the alternative will be
use an ec2 instance and set up distance
so you have to set up everything
and run and basically spin up uh the
instance for
ever potentially so
it's not really what you want to do
especially if let's say
your etl needs to be executed twice
three ten times per day it's basically
nothing
and you really want to go with a
serverless solution in this case
and i can also tell you that there are
like a lot of companies that are
basically
dependent on aws lambda so they're
basically building
all they serve all their applications on
aws lambda
and in general i mean it's a really good
way to prototype your application and
then if you need you can
you can switch to aws cdk and
now i'm not super familiar with it but i
think
so just don't take it for granted but i
think that you can
um always get
uh somehow download or get this kind of
uh docker image i think from from aws
lambda i'm not 100
sure but in general uh i think you can
since it's based on docker maybe you can
get a docker image from it
but i'm not really sure honestly you can
easily google it
uh maybe you can um
but apart from that you have
a really nice um python code that is not
dependent from
the lambda function itself um and i
think that somehow you can do whatever
you want with it so
in potentially it's really easy to in my
mind it will be really easy to switch to
another cloud provider for instance and
in the best case you
can download it as a docker image not
really sure about that
but yeah maybe you want to check it out
there's no not another question it's
kind of a
meta question what was that actually
like what would be the main difference
to
good old batch processing as i did it
i don't know 10 years ago during like at
university
yeah yeah like i mean i it reminds me
not know that i think more about it
isn't it actually a pretty old concept
like like what's the difference to
just standard batch processing on a
supercomputer
or whatever compared to lambda you mean
um i honestly i don't really know
but i mean in general maybe samantha has
like more knowledge about that
um i mean i would say
i mean usually the advantages on
uh aws lambda are first of all delta
scaling so
how would you handle that in your case
so how do you handle uh
going from a situation that
um which you have to where you have to
go and fro
go from i don't know 10 requests per day
till 1 000.
so and this is basically this this is
something really expensive
that is automatically managed by aws
for instance
yeah i think the scaling is one one
thing
um there's really there's a lot of
differences but in some ways you can
think about streaming as being sort of
like running mini batches
um so in that sense it's not
that different but
i think the way we've used it in the
past i
one thing to keep in mind is that if
you're doing traditional etl
in a scheduler like in airflow um
there's tools there that help you tell
if how the jobs are connected to each
other and if one
upstream step fails the next one won't
be able to run
all that kind of stuff um debugging if
you're chaining a bunch of lambdas
together
is still pretty hard so
i think lambdas and cloud functions are
great if you just have a one-step thing
you need to do
i think it's very suited to that use
case
um i would not recommend it once you get
to the point where you think you need to
chain a couple of them together
i would seriously start thinking about
moving to something else
um but there's really a lot of different
options now for streaming
and it depends on whether you need to
operate on
a row-by-row basis and get real-time
data back or
if you can wait for things to accumulate
and then run in batch
how long do you need to wait to get
enough data
right it's event it really depends on
whether you're looking to get aggregate
statistics or if you want to run
model and the requirements for those
things can be very different
so there's a raised hand from oren do
you want to ask directly
no thank you um thank you for
to talk sir enjoyed a lot um
i want to ask about the experience of a
developer
or data scientist or developer that
needs to assemble some model from
three other models and somehow connect
them and
debug tests and
few rounds and then pass it to someone
else and he will
the other person will find everything
that he needs and
the parameters that needs to get to the
model will
will actually get to the model and
[Music]
so i i want to ask because even without
the cloud
we didn't sort it yet you know in the
company i work at the moment
and wonder how more difficult it is
in the cloud or maybe the cloud source
everything or
if anything anyone can talk about it
do you want to go first alessandro or
should i you're gonna go first
okay um so there's a lot of new tooling
now
for helping to track model parameters
um and i really strongly recommend if
you're running into these problems that
you start looking into some of these
machine learning monitoring tools um
something like weights and biases which
i've tried recently comet
arise there's so many i can't even
remember all the names
um but they all have
the ability for you to put your
parameters in
and have them tracked basically with an
sdk and then you can tell for any given
run which parameters
ran um it's much easier to keep track in
version control
of what version and how all that stuff
is connected to each other
so sorry just my problem
even more basic not not the meta
parameters of which
how did you choose to train the model
the actual parameters that go into the
predict the header of the
so you mean in the code or yes i mean
um
yeah we had examples before age
country and someone decide maybe i need
another parameter
basically inference using the model
yes yes during the training during the
prediction
and making sure that the model gets what
it
what it expect because sometimes you
pass a json and maybe the json is
a little data frame
and then then maybe the columns the
values in the json are not the same and
thing like that
yeah the meta parameters
i i use tests for all of that i treat it
all like
data engineering just straight up data
engineering the same thing you would do
for any etl
that you double check what are all the
things i expected
going in and when it comes back out of
each step check again
did i get back all the stuff i wanted um
i make everything a keyword argument as
much as possible
i try to keep everything in pandas for
as long as i can because then i have
column names
and then i only go into a numpy matrix
for the very brief amount of time
when i have to strip off the column
names and then i map them all back again
as soon as i can
um that's the only way i found to make
it human readable and human debuggable
because i personally cannot remember if
i've got
30 parameters or whatever that i have to
keep track of
um and if somebody puts them in the
wrong order or
you forgot to sort the columns in the
data frame or whatever
yeah and i would like to add also as you
said of course you can
um you really want to stay in pandas as
much as you can
because it's just sad the columns names
um
maybe you really want to test it if you
have to use numpy but it depends on your
problem so
uh sometimes if you have to build like
really big really big metrics
uh if you have to build a build a really
really big matrix in that case
you cannot stay with pandas you cannot
use pandas
and maybe you want to run some tests uh
but it really depends on what you have
to do what kind of model you're going to
use and
yeah how how big is how big your matrix
is
yeah and also how how much sure i mean
also
it really depends on the code you're
going to write i mean is it about
uh working with this big matrix
uh for i don't know
like sending the magics between several
models and then
lose any kind of references from of the
columns of the matrix i mean it really
depends on
what you what you want to do sometimes
it's not the
big problem if you can if you can use
pandas
because you do all the information that
you that you want to have from
from the regional data sets
but yeah but you can also do spark right
in story and the clouds
helps or complicates things
[Music]
a little bit
it also can simplify things like
alessandra pointed out
and i would like to say i mean it's
somehow it also it's really it's really
it's really like bad to keep saying the
same thing but it really depends on the
problems
but the main concept for me is
okay i will i would like to start so
usually you
you really try different like uh
solutions so
i will say you start from the classical
one so you have python you have full
control of the things that you're doing
you have to run into you have to run a
lot of tests
uh of course and then the only
scenario i think of um
like only the only scenario where
actually cloud
the cloud can really helps you it's
probably when you have like a
service that works out of the box like i
don't know
sage maker or some time serious fancy
forecasting
this is probably something like a
scenario where i can say okay
maybe in this case you don't really um
you won't run into maybe a lot of
problems
but also in that case in that cases you
have to deal with a lot of constraints
because these services usually come with
a lot of responsibilities
and you do have constraints it's not
just about okay i'm going to use
sage maker i'm going to use mcedit
forecasting and it's done
so it's always part of a really big
experimentation
where you're going to try basic stuff
combine it with fancy cloud services
that you think are actually uh
you think that they're going to somehow
save you somehow
decrease the complexity but it's not
really like that
but amazon actually does a really good
job when they have to
uh sell them to us so
congratulation all right
shall we take this as closing remarks um
thank you very much for the discussion
um
thank you people are joining us also
from india and now it's 1am at night in
india
time to finish um just
very very briefly from the last slide
that was the last meet up for pilot
hamburg
in uh this year but we're already in the
planning stage for january and
there are many ways to stay connected
with us and get the latest news about
upcoming meetups um follow us on twitter
and
follow us on linkedin if you like um i
want to
thank again our two speakers and
everybody who participated and everybody
who joined us
and i want to wish you a great evening
thank you my pleasure